well there aren't that many chief rabbis
I'm only the sixth since 1854 t5 so
we've served on average about 30 years
each and that's a great luxury because
you start young and then you have a lot
of time a lot of people said to me when
I was chosen at the age of 40 to 1
you're a little young for the job and I
replied no and believe me in this job
I'll age rapidly so and indeed I found
so every 30 years or so there is a year
or so of search for the next chief rabbi
there's a vote and I want
it was established because in Britain
throughout Europe actually the Jewish
community is constituted as a religious
community and that means that the
community must have I had an official
spokesman if you like who represents the
community visa via the public visa vie
the other religious leaders the royal
family the government the Prime Minister
it's a kind of semi ambassadorial SAP
semi diplomatic role and obviously there
is a chief role I've written for the
same reason Lahav deal as it were not
quite the same thing as there is an
Archbishop of Canterbury in Britain so
there's a head of the Christian Church
though there's a head of the Jewish
community which is constituted as I say
as a religious rather than as an ethnic
community
I wanted to turn a rather staid and
quite predictable Jewish community not
very creative one into a much more
effervescent community and I think the
community really has been transformed we
do things in Anglo jury today
that are not done anywhere else in the
world or if stimulated developments
elsewhere in the world we have something
called Inwood where almost 3,000 young
people come together to study for a week
at the end of the year studying 600
different courses now loom wood has been
exported to 47 other places in the world
from Moscow to New York and Los Angeles
and almost everywhere else
so we have a very vibrant cultural life
which we didn't have before I want you
to make Anglo jury a more religiously
knowledgeable community and in 1993 a
couple of years into my chief rabbinate
when I launched my program Jewish
continuity 25 percent of Anglo Jewish
children went to Jewish day schools
today 17 years later that figure is 65
percent and rising that means we've
built more Jewish day schools in the
last 15 years than in all the previous
three hundred and fifty years of Anglo
Jewish history so I'm pretty proud of
that
but in particular I wanted to take the
Jewish voice and make it a voice in the
human conversation so I do a great deal
of broadcasting for the BBC and and
other national broadcast media I do
television programs a lot of radio I
write from the national press seven of
my books have been serialized in the
national press and when you consider
that the Jewish community in Britain is
any one half a percent of the population
of Britain it means that we have an
influence out of all proportion to our
numbers I'd like to see the Jewish voice
much more self-confident and willing to
engage with the world
because we're paranoid that is really
why I wrote the book future dense we
have defined ourselves as the people
that dwells alone we are nature's
victims everyone hates us we always find
ourselves alone when push comes to shove
our friends desert us now that is the
negative self-image of Jewish life that
is developed since the Holocaust since
9/11 with the isolation of Israel leave
return of anti-semitism to Europe and I
wrote this book because I believe that
that is the worst possible self
definition it will be first of all it is
true second of all it's thoroughly
miserable and self pitying and thirdly
it has an enormous risk of becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy if you think
you're alone you'll probably find
yourself alone and I see the Jewish
world pursuing these policies and they
are disastrous
that is the residue of anti-semitism
there's an anti-semitism out there but
if you're subjected to it for long
enough it becomes an anti-semitism in
here in its very extreme form
self-hatred but it can take all sorts of
other forms I mentioned in the book that
wonderful remark of the late slo-mo Karl
Barth who went around university
campuses all his life loving everyone
and he used to say III ask people what
are you and I know when somebody says
I'm a Catholic I know that's a Catholic
somebody who says I'm a Protestant I
know that's a Protestant somebody says
I'm just a human being I know that's a
Jew now you know let's move beyond that
and so I have defined in the book a
Judaism that we can share with the world
i define Judaism as the voice of hope in
the conversation of humankind and that's
why I really share my Judaism with a
British public that is 99.5% not Jewish
I do so broadcasting to them with a
Christian Hindu Sikh Muslim or secular
and we try and share our wisdom and you
know the result is I'm probably better
known by the non-jewish public then even
by the Jewish public and people like
that there's nothing really threatening
about Judaism because we don't try and
convert anyone so we say look guys this
is how we say things if it makes sense
to you please have it and if it doesn't
that's okay
anti-semitism is a virus that mutates I
begin you know with the Hellenistic age
where a lot of people think
anti-semitism began actually I say
although the Greeks and Romans didn't
all like the Jews there was nothing
personal that's exactly like the Mafia
to say when they're about to shoot you
nothing personal strictly business
so anti-semitism stage one really got
personal with the birth of Christianity
and the disappointment of Christians
that Jews did not accept one of their
own as the Messiah and that really was
personal because that was a hatred of
Jews not of people in general the next
mutation took place around 1096 with the
massacre of Jewish communities in
northern Europe during the First Crusade
and that's when Jews became not just the
people who rejected Christianity but a
demonic force they became the infidel
the Antichrist the children of Satan who
poisoned Wells desecrated the hosts and
killed Christian children to use their
blood to make months of the blood libel
that was that was demonic anti Judaism
mutation 3 we can date to 1879 with the
birth of this new word anti-semitism and
that was not religious hostility to
Judaism but racial hostility to Jews and
that was serious because in the end
Christians could work for the conversion
of Jews you can change your religion but
you can't change your race and therefore
all you could do was to god forbid work
for the extermination of the Jews so I'm
afraid the Holocaust was already
implicit in that word itself the 4th
mutation that we are living through now
is demonic anti-zionism it's focused
more on Jews as individuals but Jews as
a nation in their own sovereign state
and it accuses
Israel of essentially all the ills that
medieval Christians is you know we don't
poison wells but we do poison the world
peace we were responsible for every kind
of distress in the universe
70% of Pakistan is in the days following
9/11 thought that it had been dumped by
the Israelis the Israelis would blame
for the tsunami at the end of 2004
they've been blamed for more or less
everything and since it's so facto every
Jew is a Jew is a Zionist then every Jew
is a legitimate cause for attack and
that is the new anti-semitism that's
been born in our time it's every bit as
dangerous as the others but my argument
is that Jews must never fight
anti-semitism alone the victim cannot
cure the crime the hate it cannot cure
the hate and so I'm glad to say Britain
has become the first country and surely
won't be the last
where the fight against anti-semitism is
led by non-jews
well it's led by a parliamentary
committee on anti-semitism people of all
parties who monitor on a regular basis
all forms of anti-semitism that report
is fed back into government which
assembles a an interdepartmental
committee all the departments of
government that have any bearing on it
education health home office and all
that stuff and all of those committees
come together and interface with the
Jewish organizations that deal with the
symptoms of anti-semitism so it is
basically a government-led
activity and in 2009 the British Home
Office and Foreign Office convened for
the first time an international
conference of parliamentarians to fight
against anti-semitism almost all the
participants were not Jewish and this
conference was held and hosted by the
British government the next government
to do so has been the Canadian
government which will be doing so this
year and so we've taken this and and and
refused to live by this maxim that we
are the people who've dwell alone it is
true that we have enemies but it is also
true that we have many very good friends
the Jewish community in the United
States is 20 times as big as the Jewish
community in Britain so you have
critical mass we were walking through
Fifth Avenue as part of the Israel
parade in New York now the hundreds of
thousands of people that take part in
that we couldn't possibly assemble that
many people although you know we've done
not badly but the maximum we've ever got
together is 55,000 Jews in Trafalgar
Square the cheer scale of jury in
America is a quantum leap from what it
is in any European country and that is
that results in enormous diversity
creativity American Jewry is exciting in
ways that we just don't have the numbers
for
the United States does not have an
Archbishop of Canterbury it doesn't have
central institutionalized
religious leadership so there's no model
on which the Jewish community could
possibly build the United States is the
United States and I love it
Britain is Britain and it's different I
mean we have a monarch we have you know
a house of lots all this kind of stuff
which just looks crazy to an American or
either that or very ancient and it is
very ancient but it's very beautiful so
I think each country finds in some way
of being itself and every Jewish
community finds its own way of being
Jewish
that that statement really has never
been more untrue it is absolutely clear
today that given the smallness of our
community not only are there more
Muslims than Jews in Britain not only
are there more Hindus than Jews in
Britain there are more Sikhs than Jews
in Britain and if we continue to want to
have some kind of influence we're going
to need the two kinds of representative
voice but we have one is called the
Board of Deputies which defends Jewish
interests but like your conference of
presidents and the other is the chief
Riley who articulates Judaic principle
so given that the world is more unstable
Europe especially than ever before I
think every other religious community
envies us for this particular office
Muslims the Sikhs and the Hindus would
love to have such a thing but they are
not constituted to do it and so they
don't